and let it all I love it the iconic
horror film franchise scream is back
with its sixth installment this time the
action moves right here to New York City
where the four survivors from the last
film moved to escape their traumatic
memories and unwanted Fame in Scream Six
Melissa Barrera stars as Sam Carpenter a
young woman with a very dark family
Legacy that haunts her and her younger
sister this clip shows one of the
movie's most tense moments and is Sam
trying to escape the infamous ghost face
killer watch
no
you guys on me
Scream 6 is a production of Paramount
Pictures which like CBS is part of
Paramount Global Melissa Barrera joins
us now to talk about it good morning
good morning it looks so good see you
considering all you've been through so
good Melissa thank you so let's talk
about scream I mean I've been a fan of
this franchise since the beginning even
though like Tony I don't like horror
movies but I always liked scream because
of the way it keeps this Horror in
tongue-in-cheek so it's one of the most
popular film series ever when you got
the script for this one you were in the
last one what'd you think
um I was I was anxious to know what was
going to happen with my character and
they didn't give us the ending so they
didn't know the ending no they keep it
from us they only give us the first like
70 pages of script and then it's not
until we're about to shoot the ending
that they actually reveal it to us it's
like a little game they like to play we
will also not be revealed we won't
reveal but what's really cool about
screams is that in this one in
particular what the characters are all
telling each other is that anybody could
be killed by Ghostface Killer because
typically you think the heroine's not
gonna die in this one yeah but here
everybody's up for grabs anybody could
be the killer anybody could be the
victim yeah that's part of the fun
exactly I don't want to use the word fun
but that's part of this offensive
well I watched in the theater by myself
with a big screen I do not recommend
that that's terrifying you need to watch
it with people yeah sorry I couldn't be
there again yes I know I'm in the
building
I needed someone to hold me
not to mention I thought a good diaper
would work for me right about now you
like this genre you said that Melissa
told me in the green room she likes
being covered with blood and you said
it's a family movie how so well this
movie you know scream can be very
heightened in a lot of ways there's a
lot of chaos and violence and like
the Ghost Face Killer can be ruthless
but he can also be like clumsy and you
know like it's it's a very specific tone
and this specific movie is very grounded
in like the sister story then in like
the family aspect of it all yeah so
that's why I mean it's a family movie
it's R-rated it's not for I mean I don't
know my cousin lets her seven-year-old
twins watch this movie because they're a
huge man they're a huge man tell your
cousin to stop doing that but you have
to keep secrets too you don't even share
secrets with your husband or your mother
about what's going to happen I don't
tell anyone anything about the movie
first because if I keep my mouth shut I
know that I'm safer and not revealing to
anyone yes but I also want them to
experience the movie as they watch it
because it's part of the game it's such
an interactive franchise because it's a
whodunit and part of the fun of it is in
the audience being like Oh I think
that's the killer oh no that one now I
think that person's the killer because
they said something Shady or they did a
weird look and so it's part of the game
that I want them to explain it's a
repeat it who've done it it's not just
one thing it's a repeated you've done it
yeah yeah that's right so it's a family
movie we've established
not for seven-year-olds yes yeah it's a
whodunit um it's also a horror movie
right uh he wants to emphasize that it's
a horror I know because my question is
you know I I saw screen one I screamed
in it and I've not screamed since uh so
for people like me who are horror movie
hesitant yeah how do you explain the
appeal so I think scream is a great
entryway into the horror genre because
it has jump scares and it can be scary
and gory because there's a lot of blood
in it but it's also funny because it's
very selfish rare it's like poking fun
at itself there are a lot of laugh out
loud moments we had the premiere last
night in a full pack theater and there's
so much laughter too there's like a
great balance and there's really light
and like heartfelt moments too it's like
a very balanced Dynamic movie but also
it's set in New York City can we talk
about that where you see somebody
wearing a go a Ghost Face Killer mask
brandishing at night yeah you're not
gonna think twice you're gonna be like I
just got to get to work out of my way
yeah I was on my corner all the time
right so what was it like having New
York be a character in this film it
raises the stakes because this city is
what you said you know like everyone's
kind of doing their own thing and
someone can be dying in the corner and
people will be like get out of my way
you know I gotta go I've heard that
happen to me I'm like loss of people are
like can you move sorry yeah I'm walking
here Ms Ortega said it's one of the best
sets one of the most fun she's ever had
on a set you agree I agree because how
is making this thing fun for you guys
making a horror movie you wouldn't think
this and I didn't think it before I
joined this franchise it's the most
kid-like fun that you can have while
you're acting as a kid it's like
reverting back to when you're six or
seven years old you're pretending to
like you know sword fight or you know
whatever it is that you were doing with
your brothers and sisters or cousins or
you know parents or whatever and you're
covered in blood and sweat and like dirt
and you feel like a warrior you feel
like a Survivor you are a warrior
so we love seeing you in this hope you
make it and there are a lot of Easter
eggs for the fans yeah thank you very
much Scream Six is in theaters this
Friday we're coming back stick around